and now we're going to turn it over to
looking at more of the status of
programs and agencies that target MSM
here in Connecticut and we'll start off
with Kristen Drayson good morning again
everybody and I'm going to talk about
where we are right now in Connecticut
with the HIV prevention funding that we
have based on the last round of requests
for proposals that the Department issued
and I don't remember what year was now I
think it was two thousand yeah I was
2008 was it two thousand minute yes
thank you gina and you know a lot of
times we we issue our rfp we base the
rfp on the priorities of our statewide
planning group and you know we had a lot
of conversations that after the rfp
process the way things shake out you
know we kind of go it that it doesn't
feel like all the groups that should
have gotten funding got funding and you
know particularly what we'd see is that
there'd be a lot of funding that ended
up going to programs that targeted
heterosexuals and then groups like ID
use and MSM there was there were sort of
less programs targeting those groups in
proportion to the sort of infection
rates within those groups and actually a
couple years ago you know right before
we did this rfp i had been going to the
a life committee if those of you might
be familiar with the a life committee
it's sean sean lang and leaf mitchell
lead the a left committee sort of
through karke and they look at aids
legislative and funding issues and we
were having a meeting and we were
talking about the upcoming rfp and and
leap was like you know I'm just you know
I'm worried that it's gonna you know
fall out again in kind of the same way
and I was like yeah me too you know so
how could you know what I'm driving back
to work and I thought well how can we do
this you know and and one of the one of
the sort of criticisms we'd heard it the
previous RFP was that what we've done is
we've moved towards something called
funding primarily on what are called
effective behavioral interventions and
those are interventions that CDC that
they've been studied they've been
replicated and they've been shown to
actual
change people's behaviors you know
because for many years we did a lot of
programs that you know they had good
intentions but because at you know at
the time HIV was relatively new we
didn't have a lot of research to back up
what we were doing other than are we
reaching people are we talking to them
do they seem to be learning stuff but we
really didn't know if it was leading to
actual behavior change which was up is
you know ultimately necessary to reduce
new HIV infections so you know but then
on the other hand when we looked at
these affected behavioral interventions
there really wasn't a lot specifically
targeting MSM so there was kind of like
this you know kind of struggle with you
know on the one hand saying we are going
to fund effective behavioral
interventions because they've been
proven to be effective and on the other
hand you know communities going you know
what we see them we understand them but
they're not really going to work in our
community because you know we're not set
up like Chicago or New York or wherever
where these things may have been studied
and so you know I was driving back and I
thought oh wait a minute you know we
have some state funding let's take some
of that state funding and pull it out of
the big pool and we will target it to
those two groups MSM and ID you and
because it's state funding it's not tied
to our federal grant we don't have to be
so worried about adhering to you know
these affected behavioral interventions
that CDC sort of you know really pushes
us to use and if we don't use them we
have to go through this crazy stuff so
it's you know I'm not going to go there
describing that but you know the state
funding actually gave us the freedom to
allow communities to kind of be creative
we we asked them to do an evaluation if
they were going to do something but that
was it so in 2008 we had to rfps one was
for 4.5 million for all of the priority
populations identified by our planning
group and you had to do the CDC Debbie's
the CDC sanctioned interventions only we
had and that was broken out by counties
throughout the state we also had rfp
number two which was 41 million which
was limited only to IDU and MSM
and you had to do some sort of
evaluation with that but you know we
wanted to get people the the freedom to
to respond to that and you know what was
what was what was a little disappointing
at the time was that with the second RFP
I mean people could do MSM in the first
12 but if you're going to apply for MSM
it had to be doing one of the effective
behavioral interventions so you know we
had people apply under both RFPs but
with the the second RFP we had I think
19 proposals and three of them targeted
MSM you know so it's kind of like oh man
you know this in turn out the way we
were hoping at Detroit it would turn out
but these are the results in this this
is where we are right now with programs
specifically funded to do to target MSM
with HIV prevention in Hartford County
there was based on the RFP and this was
a very competitive our fee process I
need to put that out there too we ended
up getting you know for every dollar we
put out we had three dollars requested
so you know there was really a lot of it
was very competitive but in Harford
County we had one agency fund and that's
the heart for gay and lesbian health
collective they were funded to do HIV
counseling and testing crcs which is oh
my god I totally know this but I forgot
comprehensive risk counseling services
yeah that works with people that are
high risk for HIV to reduce their
behaviors on the empowerment program
which you're going to hear talk about
later on today and healthy relationships
and then on rfp number two they were
funded to do peer non-peer outreach i'm
in new haven county not actually in the
city of New Haven this is water very
Health Department waterbury Health
Department was funded to do empowerment
in in new haven county and in fairfield
county we have interfaith AIDS
ministries who are doing empowerment and
they they're in danbury and they're all
doing a great job but you know there's
something there's nothing happened in
New Haven really right now and there's
nothing happening in Bridgeport you know
to big cities where you know we have a
lot of MSM you know and there were I'm
not saying these weren't the only
applicants there was another applicant
in Hartford County but because of the
competitive nature of the bid that
applicant didn't do it because they were
they were
actually proposing to do like an
empowerment program too so but this one
this one was over there you know but
looking at what's happened since that
RFP you know between the three programs
that are doing empowerment we've got 136
participants reported to us and part of
the part of what these programs do is
they do a lot of community outreach to
kind of try to find guys that would be
interested in doing it so they're out
there you know providing education etc
etc and then they kind of find a few
that we're willing to come in and
participate in the broader groups now
just because people aren't funded
specifically to do prevention work for
MSM doesn't mean that they might not end
up working with some MSM so I just want
to acknowledge that there are providers
out there that still do reach MSM Prince
you know 143 other MSM were reached
through other interventions identified
by 34 different contractors who reported
working with them and I also want to
point out too that this data isn't our
counseling and testing data this is just
for you know interventions going out to
the community and my time is running up
soon but I want to talk about a few
things that we've done recently and in
September of September of 09 we held the
D up training and that we had some CDC
technical assistance providers come in
and that's a training on a fact of
behavioral intervention for black MSM in
Connecticut I mean black MSM and we held
it in Connecticut for our providers Rob
Cruz who's going to be talking right
after me we had him kind of go up
because i said earlier no contractors
kind of time you know we're not sure how
to address it you know so i wanted him
to go out and look a little bit more and
talk to providers and find out what are
your struggles what are your barriers
what can we do as the Department of
Public Health to kind of assist you in
working with this population and we also
started an MSM work group which actually
based on our discussions in that work
group that this conference is the result
of that we need to get people together
we need to show them you know there are
some interventions that actually work
can work in a state like Connecticut
that doesn't have huge cities with huge
you know maybe gay neighborhoods or
something like that and you know coming
up
some one thing that we have planned we
have a contract with concerned citizens
for Humanity and Darryl Decker's here
today two and one of the things he did
is this age cheer here but for those of
you know Darryl he's been working in the
field of hiv/aids for years and comes up
with really wonderful you know how to
know you never know what's going to come
out of it so I don't even know what to
call these things but you know comes up
with things that really kind of bring
people together to talk and look at an
issue and create like an image or a
piece or something that can sort of
stand on its own as a piece to maybe
influence people but also can kind of
complement the programs that people are
funded to do and you know one of the
projects we're charging be able to work
with us to do something with the MSM
community and you know I hear from all
of our program people all the time I
mean I've been hearing Danielle about a
lot of your clients lately you know and
it just you know it's crazy and you know
we're hoping we're going to be able to
reach out to our programs and say you
know rather than having us who are in
the field a lot of us in the field doing
HIV prevention to get maybe clients you
know men who are infected with HIV to
say come on help us come up and come up
with a message that will work in our
communities and in your community that
we can spread the word and get it out
there so you know in the near future
please expect to hear from us and we
hope that you'll respond and maybe work
with your clients work with the people
that you're seeing who are at risk or
HIV infected to to help us come up with
a message that will you know hopefully
kind of stop what's happening you know
with HIV and other STDs and the MSM
community and thank you all very much my
my time is up